can you tell us about the case in Brazil
the for hinia I believe it's called for
people who are unaware yeah Virginia is
how it's pronounced I mean people may
have seen James Fox's film called moment
of contact
which just came out this past year it's
really worth seeing but it's it's it's
basically a fascinating case because it
involved the capture of creatures of
enter you know
uh however you want to describe them
non-human creatures and um
there's a lot of interviews that James
has done we know that there are videos
and pictures of these creatures that
exist they were in the hospital
they died they you know their bodies and
debris from the incident were taken to
the United States apparently
um it's a very very involved case which
people have been looking into for years
and the people who the witnesses and
people involved have been terrified to
talk about it because the threats that
they've received
so I've been doing a little work on the
medical there was one uh police officer
military police officer who actually was
the one who grabbed
this entity when they were trying to
capture it and later died as a result of
that of the contact physical contact
with this entity
and so I've been doing some work I'm
James Fox is the main investigator into
this but I've been trying to help out by
looking into some of the medical
aspects of what happened to this young
man who died and seeing if that can get
records
documenting because he was in the
hospital he was treated by a bunch of
doctors there's all kinds of Records
about what happened to him and so I have
talked to some of the doctors that were
involved and I've gotten some um
documents translated which were autopsy
reports done on him that are interesting
but it's an ongoing investigation it's
not I don't have a whole lot to share
about it yet
and I hope to keep going with that but
it's it's really fascinating and um
you know what what's the potential in
that case is so what's so explosive
about it is that if we could actually
document the reality of these entities
if they're you know and we know that the
proof of that is there it's just not
coming out but think how that if you
talk about disclosure
you know think about that uh if there
could be proof and this has been in
another country so the America I'm sure
America has a lot of control over what
comes out but maybe not complete control
and you just don't know uh if some of
the people in Brazil that are that are
sitting on this information might feel
they can release it so far
they haven't and it's because they're
terrified
so the doctors they remember this person
you just say hey do you recall a case
from a few years ago about so and so no
I mean this case was hugely famous it
was covered you know by media and they
all know about it so you know you know
you just mentioned the name of the
person who died and they know exactly
who you're talking about
um yeah I know this is this is known
throughout the world and it's been
investigated for so I was took place in
the 1990s so it was a while ago but
uh they definitely know what this is
about the people you talk to
yeah do you think that private
corporations have more information on
the phenomenon than the government
I don't know about more but I think some
of the aerospace companies who are
contracted with the government probably
have a lot of have information they've
been looking into some of these the
physical materials and physical evidence
for this
and I'm not in a position to know how
much of that is shared with the
government and whether they they keep a
lot of it to themselves I mean all of
that is would be buried under special
access programs and that would all be
classified so
I'm not in any position to know about
that sure can you expand on how some
private aerospace companies may have
material how do they come in possession
of that what do they do with it
well I wish I knew more um again this is
all super sensitive stuff so I don't
know that much about it but I mean I
I've been told by sources that
aerospace companies definitely are
involved Harry Reid certainly strongly
implied this in my one interview I did
with him
um and uh others have told me this too
um and you know but how it happens and
what they know and all of those details
I don't know that's all
I forget what your exact question was
um
I just I just believe and again another
thing is the Wilson memo that famous uh
Mo written by Eric Davis references
aerospace companies being involved too
you can find it throughout
you know and I'm sure
invest you know researchers who document
all this stuff to the like people like
Richard Dolan and others probably have a
lot of information they probably have it
all organized in terms of every time
it's been referenced you know but um
well some of it I noticed from people
talking to sources off the Record who
have have knowledge of this
but I don't I don't know any specifics
because it's all
highly sensitive stuff
what do you make of the Wilson mammals
and can you outline what they are for
people who are unfamiliar
well um the the Wilson yeah the Wilson
document or the Eric Davis memo however
you want to refer to it was a series of
notes recorded by Eric Davis who's a
physicist with an absolute unbelievable
memory
um and I've talked to that guy the
details that are in his brain uh are
phenomenal so it's conceivable that he
could remember such a meeting so he had
a meeting with a man named Admiral Tom
Wilson
uh back in the 1990s again I just don't
remember the exact year but
uh and it was in a car and then after
the meeting was over he made these notes
about what would happen in that meeting
and it's in that meeting
um Avril Admiral Wilson described how he
had tried to get access to some of these
special he was I think he was a joy
Chiefs of Staff at the time again if I
had known we were going to talk about
this I would have refreshed my memory
before I came on but um he was a very
high level and he believed that he
should if there were such a program
which was looking into crashed objects
of you know non-human origin that he
would know so he went banging on doors
trying to find the location of these
programs
and he was telling Eric Davis at this
meeting that he had found one
and they acknowledged that they had a
crashed object not made by human hands
was the way they described it these
people in this program but they were not
going to allow for him access he was not
on the bigot list of people who had
access and they basically told him to go
away and then he was
told to keep his mouth shut by people
about it and not to pursue this any
further
um and that's basically what the I mean
I encourage it's fascinating to read
this memo you have to go on and read it
um and so
uh Wilson has denied that the meeting
ever happened
and Eric cannot comment on it so he
doesn't say one way or the other exactly
yeah he's not going to comment on it
um I my colleague Ralph Blumenthal and I
tried to dig into this and it's it's
very hard to get any definitive
on the record sources that could verify
anything around that memo even though
there's a lot of names in there and
stuff like that it's it's just
impossible to I mean there's been some
great research done on it I'm not the
one who's done it
by various people in the UFO research
world have done fantastic documents and
long reports on this
um which I'm trying to trouble naming
right now but um
there's a lot of information out there
about it yeah and do you take Eric
Davis's no comment as an admission of
its veracity because if it was false he
would just say no it's false does he
always say no comment no matter what
well you'd have to look and again there
are documents out there that have have
everything Eric has ever said about this
written down you know so you can look
and decide for yourself I personally
know him I believe he's an honest
individual he would not make I don't
believe personally he would make this up
so I don't believe he did make it up and
I know he has an extraordinary memory
and
you know I'll leave it at that and if
you want to analyze the way he's
responded to questions about it again
you can look I I
I bet there's somebody who could put in
the chat right now the exact document
I'm talking about it came out
within the last six months I think this
long detailed analysis
under a pseudonym by somebody who
analyzed that document
in incredible detail
somebody could probably put that in the
chat right now I just can't sure sure
who is Stuart Alexander and why is he
important to the development of your
work
uh Stuart Alexander is a physical medium
who lives in the UK who I I got involved
studying his mediumship when I was
writing my book surviving death
um and then I ended up having a lot of
experiences with him that were really
interesting and both from a you know
journalistic perspective and from a
personal perspective and I'm still very
involved with this group that worked
with him and physical mediumship is a
very strange
rare thing and you know we can go into
it if you want uh but I think a lot of
people are going to think it's pretty
weird and you know it's hard to talk
about without placing it in context of
historical context and really
giving a lot of background so that
people can accept it that how long will
that take five minutes to do that or
much longer I don't know you want to try
do you want to start and then feel like
ah no
I mean I can oh I'll give a little
synopsis but I would yeah because that's
way too much of a teaser everyone's like
oh no it's true I would hope that people
would I mean I'm not trying to sell my
book but I I spent so much time in my
book
building up to talk his mediumship was
the very end of the book right and I
spent many chapters contextualizing it
showing the history showing scientific
studies that have been done on people
similar to him in the past that were
absolutely you know
irrefutable in terms of documenting the
abilities the same abilities he has that
have been documented in other people by
scientists in published books of papers
I mean I just had to set the context for
this because it's too weird if you just
dump it on somebody yeah it's all there
if you want to read about it and the
other thing is that Stuart Alexander if
you go to my website which is Leslie
kane.com and go under surviving death
I think it's called book materials or
something like that there is a a video
of Stuart's uh two-part fairly lengthy
video of him describing his whole
development and journey as a physical
medium and I would encourage anybody
who's curious
to go listen to him and you get a real
sense of who he is as a person and how
sincere and genuine he is I mean and you
it'll you'll also learn directly from
him how he developed these abilities
what they're about why he does them you
know all the things that people want to
know but in a nutshell what physical
media ship is and I'm going to base that
around what I've experienced with Stuart
Alexander is that um
it he's he's he goes into a room with a
group of people who he works with
regularly every week and I I've sort of
become part of this group only I do a
lot of it through the computer here in
New York I link into their meetings
but um I've been to the inside that
group many many times and experienced
all these things myself so
um and the initial thing is you of
course eliminate any possibility of
there being trickery and I'm not going
to spend time describing how I did that
but I
scrutinized everything that was going on
to make sure there were no no no ways
this could be done through cheating or
trickery
um and you know what happens is he goes
into a trance state where he basically
leaves he's unconscious and then these
entities who are supposedly beings from
the afterlife
come into his body and make use of his
vocal cords basically to communicate
with people in the room and they they
um perform all these physical miraculous
physical things that you can witness
that everybody in the group can witness
at the same time so it's objective
and it's in the dark but things are lit
up enough some things are not in the
dark so that you can you know you can
see enough of what's going on depending
on what the actual experiment is they
call them experiments and the dark is
important the dark is important because
and again this is the thing that could
make us go on for half an hour about
this you know and I do go into a lot of
this in my book and I know people find
it suspicious that it has to be in the
dark but it's been the it's just the way
he developed and a lot of mediums
develop because there's a substance that
is used that is exuded from his body to
to make these physical phenomena happen
that is extremely sensitive to light
and that's just the way it is and people
can say oh it's just so that they can
fake things in the dark you know but
it's just not the way it is uh and the
physical substance is that something
that you can capture and then you could
measure that or like an energy substance
I mean people have tried to capture and
take it into a lab
but it kind of disintegrates it's
basically all that's left is some of the
saliva from The Medium because it's
exuded from his mouth
or it can be exuded from other parts of
this body but you know it's it's more
energy but it's it can solidify I mean
this all sounds like magic and it's like
magic there's this stuff is emitted can
solidify into something solid
and what it does is it it can move so
then what you witness as a person in the
room is an object
um moving around the room you witness
all kinds of levitation and physical
objects moving around the room because
this substance is attaching themselves
to it but you don't see the substance so
you're witnessing there's this thing
called a trumpet which is a
cone-shaped object which is a tradition
they use in physical mediumship and it's
got this illuminated band around the end
of it so that even though you're in the
dark you can see it
and you can watch this thing go up into
the sky and fly all over the room and
bang on the walls and go to the ceiling
and touch you right in a perfect spot in
your forehead
answer you know respond to requests and
move around and that's one thing is this
levitation of this object the trumpet
responds to requests it will respond
like if you say it'll it'll yeah and
sometimes a voice will speak through the
trumpet
a disembodied voice I've heard that
numerous times I mean you cannot wrap
your mind around this yeah I see why
you're saying now that several chapters
lead up to this exactly because it's
like people think this is completely
nuts and it's very hard for me to talk
about because of that it's so sensitive
and I know that it's real because I've
I've done my due diligence and I've been
involved with it for seven years or
something and I know everybody in that
group very well and I know Stuart very
well
um and I you know there's absolutely
it's real that's without question it's
been witnessed by hundreds of people not
just me
um over the years you know so but it's
very I find it hard to talk about and I
I gave a uh I was invited to give a talk
about this for Rice University last year
at their archives of the impossible
conference who's held by Jeffrey kreipel
a professor there and I talked about
this because he asked me to he asked me
to talk about this
because Stuart Alexander's archives are
now with the uh Rice University
collection all his archives have been
donated with my help to Rice
and it was very very difficult for me to
talk about this and if people want they
can go and look at the talk I gave and
that's another way you can get a sense
of seriousness of this and the history
of it I I was so nervous doing it Kurt
it's so sensitive it's very personal and
very strange and hard for people to
accept as real for good reason
so I just find it hard to talk about
that you know for that reason but I
you'll see that when I if you watch this
talk I gave that I was pretty nervous
about it and I acknowledge that but you
know there's also things like the
materializations of things happen
so you know I have experienced numerous
times as of others in the light you can
see this
a hand materialized out of nothing
on a on a table and I was able to touch
this materialized hand
and then
so you know what do you want to make of
that uh and what is the hand supposed to
represent someone who is no longer with
us yeah it's it's it's
um one of the spirit people that's what
we call them for lack of a better word
the spirit people who works through
Stuart
uh is actually
materializing his own hand
by
placing it in I mean the way he
describes it is he's just slowing down
his vibration enough within the
substance that's exuded from the from
the uh medium which is called ectoplasm
and people probably laugh when they hear
that word
the spirit has a high vibration
well the way they describe it and kid I
can't answer all these questions of
course of course I lost the threat of
the sentence it was a complicated
sentence so wait the spirit has a high
vibration they slow it down and they use
a substance to slow themselves down or a
substance is given off as a result but
their etheric hand into it I mean this
is how you know again again I'm just
telling you what I was sure
so they have to lower they have to lower
their vibration to just be in our
physical world and manifest physically
to Manifest this hand so they somehow
there's an etheric hand there's a a
non-physical hand that exists and that
non-physical the Thera can is placed
inside this
materials stuff called ectoplasm and
then by slowing it by by somehow he's
able to materialize that hand I mean I
don't know how I I'm sure all I know is
I've witnessed it numerous times and so
of many other people
um and it's one of it is probably the
most mind-blowing experience I've ever
had in my life
you know uh and but it's documented it's
been written about but you know it's
it's not it would never satisfy a
scientist unless they went in that room
and experience it for themselves
you know a scientist just hearing me say
that is going to think it's ridiculous
but
if they go in that room and experience
it for themselves and have and you know
can can satisfy themselves that there's
no trickery going on uh
you're stuck with this how does it
happen you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy